so what's a colloid engine
so the same rocket people
that um came up with
with these ideas for electric propulsion
um probably in the middle of last
century
also realize that there's one more place
to get
charged particles from if you're going
to be using electric propulsion so
you can take a gas and you can ionize it
but there are also
some liquids particularly ionic liquids
which is what we use
that you also can use as a source of
ions and if you have
ions and you put them in a field you
generate a force so
they recognize that but
part of being able to leverage that
technique is being able to
kind of manipulate those liquids on a
scale of nanometers
or or you know very few microns so you
know the
diameter of a human hair or something
like that and
in the 50s there was no way to do that
so they wrote about it in some books and
then
it kind of died for a little bit and
then
with um silicon mems computer processors
and
and when foundry started becoming more
ubiquitous
and my advisor started at
mit uh kind of put those
ideas back together and was like hey
actually there is now a way to
build this and bring this other
technique to life
um and so the way that the way that you
actually get the
the ions out of those liquids is you put
the liquid in a
in again a strong electric field and the
electric field stresses the liquid
and you keep increasing the field and
eventually the liquid will assume
uh a conical shape um
it's the it's when the electric field
pressure that's pulling on it
exactly balances the liquids own
restoring force which is its surface
tension
so you have this balance and the liquid
assumes a cone
when it's perfectly balanced like that
and at the tip of a cone
the radius of curvature goes to zero
right at the tip
and the radius sorry the electric field
right at the tip of a sharp object would
go to
infinity uh because it goes um
as one over the radius and one over the
radius squared
and instead of the electric field going
to
infinity and maybe like generating a
wormhole or something
um a jet of ions instead starts you know
issuing from the tip of
of that liquid so the field becomes
strong enough there that you can pull
ions um out of the liquid what is the
liquid
we're talking about there's a bunch of
different ones
you can do it with um with different
types of
liquids it depends on you know how
easily you can free
ions from their neighbors and if it has
enough surface tension
so that you can build up a high enough
electric field but
what we use are called ionic liquids and
they're really just positive
they're they're very similar to salts
but they happen to be liquid over a
really
wide range of temperatures this sounds
like really cool
okay so how big is the uh how big is the
kona we talk uh
what what's the size of this cone that
generates that if you have a cone that's
emitting pure ions
um the i can't remember if it's the
radius or diameter but
um that emission is happening from
of that cone is something like 20
nanometers oh
i was imagining something slightly
bigger but so like this is
so this is tiny tiny yes hence the
only being able to do it recently yeah
that's right so this is all controlled
by a computer i guess
like or like how do you control
how do you create a cone that generates
ions on a scale of nanometers
exactly so the kind of main
trick to making this work is that
physically we manufacture
hundreds or thousands of sharp
structures and then supply the liquid to
the
tips so that does a few things
um it makes sure that we know where the
ion beams are forming so we can put
holes in the grid above them to let them
actually leave
instead of hitting right cool but it
also reduces
the actual field we have to the voltage
we have to apply to create that field
because the field will be much stronger
if we can already
give the liquid a tip to form on
and those tips we form have radii of
curvature
on the order of probably like single
microns
so we are working at a little bit larger
scale but once we
create that support and the electric
field can be focused at that tip then
the tiny little cone can form
so wait so there's something in them
there's an already like a hard material
that like gives you the base for the
cone and you're pouring like liquid over
it
from the bottom yeah it's porous so we
actually supply it from the back of the
chip and then liquid forms on top yeah
on that structure yeah and then you
somehow make it like super sharp the
liquid
so the ions can leave
and then we've applied that field to get
those ions and that same field then
accelerates them that's awesome and
there's like a bunch of these
yeah i should have i should have brought
something
um so we you could just pretend that you
have some nanometer
cones on so actually you know kind of
about this scale
um we build we call them thruster chips
and it's just a convenient form factor
and it's a square centimeter
and on each square centimeter today we
have about 500
of the actual physical we call them
emitters those physical
cones um and we're working on
increasing that by a factor of four in
the coming months in
size or in number and the density the
number of
emitters within the same square
centimeter chip so that thing because i
think i've seen pictures of you with
like a tiny thing
yeah and that must be the thing okay so
that's an
engine um so that is
kind of the ionization chamber and
thrust producing part of it
what's not shown you know in that
picture
um is the propellant tank so we can keep
supplying more and more of the liquid to
those
emission sites and then we also provide
a power electronic system
that talks to the spacecraft and turns
our device on and off
so that's the colloid engine that's the
core of the coolant
um it's the way i've been talking about
it it's
um more of ion electrospray colloid
um tends to mean like
liquid droplets coming off of the jet
but if you
make smaller and smaller cones you get
pure ions
so we're kind of like a subset of
colloid yes what
uh aspects of this you said that it's
been full of mystery
from the physics perspective what
aspects of this are understood
and what are still full of mystery
yeah recently um
we've been understanding the kind of
instabilities and and stable regimes of
you know how much liquid do you supply
and and what field do you apply
and um why is it flickering on and off
or why does it have these weird
behaviors so that's
in the past just couple years that's
become much more
understood um i think the two
areas that come to mind as far as um
not as well understood are um
the boundary between you know you have
um we we actually use kind of big
molecular
ions and if you're looking at
the molecular scale you have
you know some ions that you've extracted
and they're in this electric field
one ion you know it's a big molecule
it's getting
energy from the electric field and some
of that energy is going into the bonds
and making it
vibrate and doing weird things to it
sometimes it breaks them apart
and then zooming out to the whole beam
the beam has some behaviors as this beam
of ions
and there's a big gap between what are
those what how do you connect those
and how do we understand that better so
that we can understand the beam
performance of
of the engine is that a theory question
or an engineering question
theory definitely where axion is a
startup and
we're more in the business of building
and testing and observing
and characterizing and we're not really
diving much into
that theory right now
you